[Musique]
bienvenue dans ce nouveau numéro de
skimmac spécial handicap et emploi à
l'occasion de la Semaine européenne pour
l'emploi des personnes handicapées qui a
lieu du 14 au 20 novembre et pour en
parler François Morton bonjour bonjour
Patrice carmouz vous êtes le père de
Guyancourt vous êtes vice-président
délégué à la politique de la ville à la
santé et au solidarité et donc la
question du handicap fait évidemment
partie de des dossiers que vous gérez
alors quand on parle de handicap on
parle souvent de d'aménagement ce qui
est nécessaire c'est-à-dire l'accès aux
transports l'accès aux services publics
mais ce qu'il faudrait pas aller plus
loin parler aussi de l'accès à la
culture de l'accès aux loisirs et de
l'accès évidemment à l'emploi alors vous
avez parfaitement raison lorsqu'on
traite cette question du handicap et des
personnes handicapées on a souvent
tendance à aborder la question avec ce
qu'on appelle de la compensation et de
la compensation matérielle et donc on a
on adapte des équipements publics par
exemple des bâtiments et donc on a
vraiment besoin d'aller au-delà de ça
maintenant parce que les communes les
collectivités ont l'habitude de le faire
les sociétés aussi mais il faut qu'on
aille bien au-delà de ça maintenant et
notamment évidemment l'emploi on va on
va en parler puisqu'il y aura il y aura
beaucoup d'événements
pendant cette semaine européenne et je
vous propose tout de suite de voir un
sujet on va faire conscience de Valérie
valérie est entré chez enedis elle est
atteint d'un handicap mais elle a trouvé
cette entreprise à la suite justement du
Forum Emploi et handicap qui a eu lieu
au mois de mars dernier à
saint-quentin-en-y avec plaisir
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la médecine du travail est passée ce
matin pour voir un petit peu comment
pouvait aménager mon poste de travail
pour que
mon environnement soit plus confortable
et plus adapté à ma pathologie
[Musique]
ça fait partie d'une de la vie de
l'entreprise à plus s'ouvrir jusqu'à
présent moi j'avais le statut de travail
handicapé j'ai jamais utilisé c'est la
première fois que je l'utilise c'est pas
un privilège c'est simplement prendre en
compte certaines manques peut-être un
petit peu plus de pénibilité et de
fatigue habilité sur le poste qu'on peut
être amené à
occuper et avoir certains aménagements
pour que on puisse travailler pleinement
avec toutes nos capacités
un écran plus grand un siège plus
enveloppant qui tient compte de la
pénibilité au niveau du dos des choses
comme ça pour que on puisse nous
accompagner à continuer à travailler et
exercer le métier qu'on aime et qu'on a
envie de faire
[Musique]
chez enedis ma reconnaissance de
travailleur handicapés a été demandé
vraiment en fin de processus de
recrutement donc ça c'est déjà
appréciable ça veut dire que finalement
vous êtes déjà recruté sur des
compétences et pas par rapport à un
statut après il y a une RH dédiée aux
personnes handicapées
[Musique]
le forum d'emploi pour les personnes
handicapées qui a eu lieu au Vélodrome
les entreprises qui sont là recherchent
des profils ça représente une réelle
opportunité et des vraies rencontres
entre les entreprises qui demandent et
les gens qui recherchent
[Musique]
François Berton vient de voir Valérie
qui a plusieurs sortes de handicap et
elle elle est capable de ce qu'on
appelle un handicap invisible oui et
puis c'est important de pouvoir
illustrer cette question du handicap
autour de sujets comme celui-ci alors
vous dites vous-même sur ce territoire
Guyancourt vous prenez soin de proposer
aux personnes handicapées un cadre qui
est à la fois exigeant mais qui était
aussi bienveillant
ça veut dire quoi concrètement alors il
est essentiel effectivement lorsque l'on
accueille une personne en situation de
handicap puisqu'on parle aussi d'emploi
et d'emploi aussi dans nos collectivités
d'avoir à la fois cette exigence comme
pour n'importe quel salarié n'importe
quel travailleur je crois que c'est
important de remettre cette personne en
situation de handicap autour de l'emploi
et dans l'emploi et en même temps
d'avoir procédé auparavant à une vraie
analyse des besoins pour pouvoir
effectivement l'accompagner et l'aider
au quotidien on va parler de cette
semaine européenne de l'emploi du 14 au
20 novembre
il y a notamment
le duod le 17 le 17 novembre qu'est-ce
que c'est le duod alors le duod on
fabrique enfin des duos des binômes je
devrais être mais je pense que le terme
de binôme d était peut-être compliqué à
dire mais le duodé c'est effectivement
une personne en demande en recherche
d'emploi en situation de handicap
puisque tel est le cas qui va être
associé durant toute une journée avec un
salarié d'une entreprise qui va lui
faire découvrir le métier voire
plusieurs métiers parce que l'idée aussi
peut-être de découvrir plusieurs métiers
dans lesquels il pourrait se retrouver
ensuite d'accord c'est vrai que ce
contact entre les handicapés les
handicapés évidemment fondamentales et
puis on a sur ce territoire on l'a vu
avec Valérie et enedis des entreprises
qui sont très engagées dans ce dans ce
dans ce combat j'allais dire pour
l'emploi des personnes handicapées on a
sur le territoire de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines la chance
d'avoir des ce qu'on appelle des Grands
Comptes un des grandes entreprises mais
pas que ces grandes entreprises des
entreprises de taille modestes peuvent
participer aussi à ce combat puisque
c'est comme ça que vous vous l'avez
appelé en tout cas l'accompagnement de
ces personnes handicapées dans le cadre
de l'emploi et c'est vrai qu'elle joue
le jeu globalement ces grandes
entreprises globalement vous diriez que
la situation est meilleure aujourd'hui
pour des personnes dans
situation de handicap alors j'ai envie
de dire oui voilà de manière très claire
j'ai la chance d'avoir eu un parcours
professionnel notamment dans le champ du
handicap depuis 25 ans maintenant et
j'ai pu voir l'évolution j'ai vu
l'arrivée de la loi de 2005 qui est
d'une loi fondatrice pour pour les
personnes en situation de handicap et
effectivement alors moi j'étais plutôt
dans le milieu scolaire dans celui de
l'emploi mais c'est un lien direct bien
évidemment puisque ce sont des lieux de
formation et notamment de formation pour
ensuite arriver dans le dans le monde de
l'emploi et oui il y a de vrais vrais
vrais vrais vrais progrès qui sont faits
maintenant beaucoup restent à faire
encore notamment pour essayer de
d'abandonner un certain nombre de
préjugés voilà je crois que ce terme il
est important et puis de se dire qu'on
peut qu'on est capable voilà merci
beaucoup François porterola celui-ci au
ski cube et c'est là que démarre
beaucoup de startups dont une qui a été
lancé par un homme qui s'appelle Laurent
Lapierre qui était un autocycliste qui a
eu un accident de moto qui est devenu
handicapé et qui a inventé le
ça permet de de transformer des
fauteuils roulants de personnes
handicapées au fauteuil roulant
électrique ce qui est également leur
change la vie et la développer ici au
ski cube on regarde cette invention de
Laurent la pierre lors d'une autre
[Musique]
on est parti de rien en gros de trois
slides et d'une idée
[Musique]
l'idée n'est d'un accident que j'ai eu
il y a 5 ans en moto qui m'a mis en
fauteuil j'ai passé un an dans un centre
de rééducation où j'ai essayé pas mal de
choses pour motoriser les fauteuils
roulants manuels et puis on
réfléchissant comme ça mais je veux dire
un bâton rompu moi j'estime mais
pourquoi il existe pas un truc sur
lequel on monte on s'accroche et on part
quel que soit le fauteuil allez tonton
l'aventure
[Musique]
c'est loin d'une autre qui sera
disponible dans des centres commerciaux
donc tu vois ça c'est le prototype donc
il y a pas de carénage voilà c'est un
peu c'est un peu bout de ficelle l'idée
c'est c'est de s'approcher du
handynautes de mettre les roues avant de
poser des roues entre les mâchoires là
qu'on voit là donc je fais pas parce que
c'est un prototype une fois que ce sera
prêt on appuiera sur un bouton qui va
fermer les mâchoires donc fermer les
mâchoires sur les roues avant
la platine va se relever on attrape le
guidon l'idée c'est que ce sollordinaire
soit personnalisable dans un premier
temps couleur d'une entreprise mais
pourquoi pas dans un deuxième temps
quand le particulier pour l'acheter
personnalisable vraiment assez goût si
on revient sur un univers moto vélo par
exemple si je suis moto je suis
peut-être plus Saré ou building ou
Yamaha ou etc et quand j'achète une moto
je peux je peux choisir mes couleurs
voir mes mon accastillage etc
[Musique]
c'est pas parce qu'on est dans le
handicap qu'on a besoin de solutions
uniquement pratiques ça peut être sympa
aussi d'avoir des choses qui nous
ressemblent et à la fois pour la
personne en situation de handicap
vis-à-vis de ce qu'elle leur envoie
comme image à elle et aux autres et puis
aussi pour les personnes valides pour se
dire bah tiens ah vous avez ça comment
ça se passe etc
quand on attaquera le particulier pour
en fait faire des séries limitées avoir
des matières différentes ou voir des
formes ou des couleurs différentes
[Musique]
je le fais un peu à la américaine ou les
Américains ont une devise qui listing
big pour ces gros si on se dit
aujourd'hui c'est que la France et qu'on
a un concurrent qui se dit c'est pas mal
et qui s'implante en Europe et dans le
monde alors qu'on aurait pu y aller là
ça va être frustrant et puis on verra
bien
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on va aborder maintenant la question des
relations entre les entreprises et les
personnes en situation de handicap avec
les abords bonjour
vous êtes chargé de mission handicap et
employeur de Cap Emploi 78 d'abord
quelles sont les missions de des grandes
missions de Cap emploi alors on a une
mission de service public on accompagne
les personnes en situation de handicap
vers et dans l'emploi donc pour la
recherche d'emploi et le maintien en
emploi pour les salariés alors on a
parlé beaucoup de cette semaine
européenne
consacrée à l'emploi des personnes en
situation de handicap
quels sont les grands événements font
que vous retenez de cette semaine on
organise pas mal d'événements sur cette
semaine là notamment des sessions de
recrutement avec beaucoup d'entreprises
du territoire un petit peu partout dans
le 78 au sein de nos locaux au Cap
emploi mais aussi dans les agences Pôle
emploi pendant toute la semaine pour
l'emploi des personnes handicapées et on
peut aussi participer audio des pour les
entreprises et les personnes c'est une
journée où on accueille une personne en
situation de handicap au sein de son
entreprise pour lui faire découvrir ou
un métier un secteur d'activité ou
l'entreprise dans sa globalité quel
justement quels sont les conseils que
vous pouvez donner aux entreprises ou
représentant des entreprises dans ces
duodé alors pour les dieux modèles le
conseil qu'on donne c'est vraiment de
pouvoir
intégrer la personne et lui faire voir
un maximum de choses sur cette
journée-là donc partagez la journée avec
plusieurs salariés dans plusieurs
services différents pour que la personne
puisse se faire une idée la plus globale
possible de l'entreprise et de son
activité et sensibiliser les salariés à
l'accueil de cette personne là pour que
tout se passe au mieux depuis votre
votre site qui est un site d'observation
important Cap Emploi est-ce que vous
diriez que la situation des personnes en
situation de handicap c'est plutôt
améliorer par rapport à l'emploi oui je
dirais que ça s'améliorer les chiffres
le prouvent aussi notamment on en tire
un Béné de cette crise sanitaire c'est
qu'avec le télétravail on a eu beaucoup
de personnes qui ont pu avoir accès à un
emploi qui qui est beaucoup plus
compatible avec leur restriction
puisqu'ils plus les transports et que le
télétravail est majoritairement présent
dans les entreprises maintenant donc ça
facilite beaucoup l'adaptation des
personnes en situation de handicap face
à l'emploi parce que ça veut dire que
des évolutions qui n'avaient rien à voir
avec avec le handicap ou plutôt
faciliter le l'insertion de ces
personnes ça c'est ça c'est formidable
et ça fait aussi une prise de conscience
de l'autre côté de du côté des
employeurs ça bien
ils se rendent compte aussi que les
besoins d'aménagement des personnes en
situation de handicap ne sont pas
nécessairement très coûteux et
qu'effectivement quelques jours de
télétravail par semaine peut être
suffisant pour une personne en situation
de handicap pour tenir son poste dans
les meilleures conditions il y a quelque
chose qui est très important et pour
nous tous mais aussi pour les personnes
en situation de handicap c'est le
numérique et je vous propose d'aller
faire un tour la pop school d'Élancourt
justement avec deux personnes en
situation de handicap l'une qui s'est
formée au numérique pour une formation
et l'autre pour une reconversion
[Musique]
avant j'étais menuisier je me suis
finalement blessé au dos du haut pour de
charge c'est pour ça que maintenant j'ai
voulu me réorienter vers les bureaux
d'études donc dans le numérique à
l'heure actuelle dans le bâtiment ça
évolue énormément à la fois sur le DD
mais aussi sur le 3D donc c'est vraiment
pour ça que j'ai choisi cette formation
là pour vraiment performer dans ce dans
cette direction
[Musique]
top school c'est un organisme de
formation solidaire inclusif on
s'adresse à des personnes en
reconversion en recherche d'emploi alors
situation de handicap ou pas et on le
forme toutes ces personnes au métier du
numérique puisque ce sont des métiers
qui recrutent et sur lequel il y a
vraiment des gros besoins de techniciens
plutôt donc ça va des personnes qui vont
être opérationnelles tout de suite
[Musique]
j'ai voulu rester dans toujours dans le
milieu du bâtiment de la lecture de plan
établir les relevés quantitatifs
estimatif faire des devis avoir un lien
avec les fournisseurs les clients ça
pourrait être une suite c'est comme si
j'avais poussé mes études bien plus loin
et avoir plus de responsabilités
[Musique]
c'est pas évident de se dire que on va
aller demander à un statut de
travailleurs handicapé pour travailler
surtout si on a un handicap qui n'est
pas visible extérieurement et je pense
pas que ce soit ça que je vais mettre en
avant vaut mieux mettre en avant à mon
avis un professionnel
savoir faire ses compétences l'employeur
lui sa première motivation c'est d'avoir
quelqu'un qui lui donne un travail
efficient
[Musique]
sur les trois sujets qu'on vient de voir
dans cette émission deux concerts celui
qu'on vient de voir et puis le premier
sujet des personnes dont le handicapé
invisible c'est une majorité de
handicapés c'est vrai c'est 80% des
handicaps qui sont invisibles et c'est
vrai que au cours de cette semaine là
notamment avec beaucoup d'actions comme
les sessions de recrutement et le
duodest ça permet aux entreprises de se
rendre compte que effectivement la
majorité des handicaps sont invisibles
et ne nécessitent pas forcément
d'aménagement et dernière question
peut-être vous travaillez évidemment
toute l'année sur cette question de
l'emploi des personnes en situation de
handicap
c'est important d'avoir des focus comme
Valette cette semaine européenne tout à
fait c'est important parce que ça permet
à certaines entreprises de de s'y mettre
parce que malheureusement toutes les
entreprises ne sont pas encore dans
cette dynamique là ça s'améliore et
notamment grâce à des actions nationales
comme ça comme cette semaine là merci
beaucoup les abords merci à vous et
merci à tous et à très vite pour un
nouveau numéro de ski mag
[Musique]